la suma de tres enteros consecutivos
impares es 231 cuál es el más grande de
estos enteros y bueno pensemos un poco
en este problema si yo digo que x es el
entero más pequeño de estos tres enteros
consecutivos entonces lo voy a escribir
aquí x es el más pequeño de estos
enteros consecutivos impares y con esto
entonces cuál es el siguiente entero
impar no sé imagínate que x vale 3 si x
vale 3 el siguiente entero impar sería 5
y el siguiente sería 7 y el siguiente
sería 9 y así nos podremos seguir y
seguir y seguir date cuenta que lo único
que estoy haciendo es sumando 2 así que
si x es el más pequeño de estos enteros
impares x más 2 cds consecutivo entero
en par de equis y bueno ya que tenemos
que estos son enteros éste se enteró
también entonces el siguiente entero en
par sería x + 2 más 2 es decir x 4 x + 4
va a ser
grande de estos enteros impares o dicho
de otra manera el consecutivo de estos
enteros impares de x2 fíjate que de 3 a
7 sumamos 4 o de 5 9 sumamos 4 y
entonces me dicen que la suma de estos
tres consecutivos enteros impares es 231
es decir que la suma de x + x + 2 + x +
4 la suma de estos tres me tienen que
dar 231 vamos a notarlo porque esto es
muy importante x + x + 2 + x 4
esto tiene que ser igual a 231 y me
preguntan cuál es el mayor de estos
enteros pues para esto sería muy bueno
saber cuál es el valor de x
dada esta ecuación de primer grado y
para esto voy a sumar las x x + xx es 3x
y por otra parte tengo dos más cuatro lo
cual es 6 2 4 6 y esto tiene que ser
igual a 231 esto es igual a 231 y ahora
de aquí ya tengo una ecuación muy fácil
de resolver para x lo primero que voy a
hacer es restar 6
los lados de la ecuación así que menos 6
aquí menos 6 acá y me queda 3x porque
estos dos se van 3x es igual a 231 menos
6 231 menos 6 esto es lo mismo que 225
225 perfecto 3x es igual a 225 y ahora
para obtener el valor de x lo que voy a
hacer es dividir ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre 3 entonces 3 entre 3 se
van y me queda solamente que x es igual
a wow
225 entre 3 y ahora si x es igual a 225
entre 3 vamos a hacer esta división por
acá 225 entre 3
primero 3 cada vez 22 7 veces 7 por 3 es
21 entonces 22 - 21 me dan uno solamente
1 y bajo el 5 y después me queda 15
entre 3 lo cual es sin costo está muy
fácil 5 x 3 es 15 y entonces 15 menos 15
a 0 y es una división exacta por lo
tanto x vale 75 el entero impar más
chico de sus tres s 75 x vale 75 y una
vez que ya sabemos cuánto vale x
entonces el siguiente entero impar
consecutivo a 75 pues va a ser 77 ya
tenemos el segundo y por último el más
grande de estos enteros impares o el
consecutivo a 77 es x + 4 lo cual es 79
y ya con esto tengo la respuesta cuál es
el entero más grande pues la respuesta
va a ser 79 79 y sería muy bueno
verificar que en efecto me diera la suma
de estos 3 231 así que 75 más es más
déjenme poner lo mejor de esta manera 75
9 y vamos a sumar los todos 57 12 9 es
21 y llevamos 22 799 7 es 16 16 más 7 es
20 y 23 perfecto entonces la suma de
estos tres enteros impares y
consecutivos es 231 date cuenta que
estos tres son enteros son impares y son
consecutivos y el más grande de estos es